>>Laura: Good morning!
>>Every year when I present
this challenge, I wonder,
will this be the year that students
will say, "No, I can't do this"?
Yet, every year, I see those
kids have a story to tell.
>>So, planners out and
notebooks and pen or pencil.
>> When I look back on my own
learning about reading and writing,
there was not a lot of writing
that I felt ownership over.
I've always been most comfortable
with writing expository nonfiction,
and when I heard about NaNoWriMo, I
thought, 8th-graders writing a novel?
That's impossible!
And I couldn't even imagine
writing a novel.
>>You guys are ready for
the 30-day challenge?
>>As far as projects
go, this one is big.
NaNoWriMo stands for National Novel
Writing Month, and it's a challenge
for young writers to write a
novel in the 30 days of November.
>>You'll start brainstorming
what settings are going
to be part of your story.
>>A lot of them say, "I can't do this.
I'm afraid.
I don't want to do it."
The counselors say that kids will
show up at their office saying,
"Please move me out of
Mrs. Bradley's class.
Does she know I'm only 13?"
So, one of the first
challenges was my own fear
that they would not have
stories to tell.
>>Student: Okay, what's your setting?
>>Laura: When I had them brainstorm
their stories and then we all sat
in a circle and I had them share out,
one after another, I was blown away
at the creativity and the passion,
the voices that they had
that they needed to share.
>>Student: The opening scene
of my novel will be a flashback
to my main character's grandfather
in the prisoner-of-war camp.
>>Student: He's eating
take-out Chinese with his mom,
who just got out of open-heart surgery.
>>Student: "And from up above,
Leo looked down at young Leo.
He looked down and smiled.
He smiled for Leo for moving
on, for saving the universe.
Well, the two of them."
>>Laura: That's amazing.
>>These students speak
with such authority.
They know what the characters
are going to do.
They know where the plot is going.
They know the conflicts that
have to be worked through,
and they know how it all will end.
>>I'm peeking over your
shoulders, and it's just amazing.
I'm so impressed.
>>I remember as a student being pretty
excited to take my writing and staple it
into a pretty construction-paper cover.
And that was publishing.
But my students now are able to send
the Amazon link to their relatives
and share their novel with the world.
I hope that they recognize
that what used
to seem impossible really
is possible for them
and that they leave my class going on
to high school identifying as a writer,
that when a teacher asks them to write
something, they in their mind will say,
"I can do this, because
I've written a novel."